all be made to eat I lived about season
three but it is um I mean without a
shadow of a doubt it's gonna be epic
it's gonna be big hey youtubers it's
Charlie so comic-con is coming up and
they just made some big announcements
for a game of thrones season 4 so I
thought I'd do a little bit of a preview
about what we're going to find out at
comic-con and what's going on with
season 4 so last year george RR martin
actually moderated the comic-con panel
he's not doing it this year but he is on
the panel he's doing a lot of other
stuff at the con but let me just read
off some of the people who will be there
John Bradley he plays Samwell Emilia
Clarke who we all know is Danny Nikolaj
coster-waldau is Jamie Peter Dinklage is
Tyrion Michelle Fairley as Catelyn Stark
/ Lady Stoneheart kit harington and rose
leslie and richard madden even though a
lot of things happen to them at the end
of season three I don't want to spoil it
if you haven't seen those episodes yet
you should check it out it's pretty
gruesome and pretty awesome so a couple
of the big names that were left off or
Lena Headey sophie Turner and Maisie
Williams who are all like a big presence
I feel like they're all running this
viral vine campaign right now this
really funny Maisie Williams and sophie
Turner are pretty hilarious so if you're
not following them on Twitter you should
check them out so why aren't they going
to be there well season 4 actually just
started filming this week so obviously
there's no footage yet they're going to
show off so they won't be showing off
any footage from season four at the
panel they will be talking a lot about
behind the scenes of what's going on
what they're doing differently with
season 4 and maybe even some teasers for
the future of the series that is just
the television series george RR martin
himself is actually doing a separate
panel just for some of his novels he's
not going to be talking a lot about a
song of ice and fire material i'll be
talking about some of these other books
so the actual game of thrones panel is
friday afternoon i'll be uploading the
footage from that panel late that night
so be sure to subscribe to get that
video i'll also be posting a rundown of
all the really important stuff they talk
about and any good spoilers so if you
remember i did a casting video for the
red Viper they just cast that role and
there's still a couple rolls they
haven't announced yet like mace Tyrell
so I have a feeling that we're going to
find out who some of those cast members
are at the panel they're obviously not
going to be there just because
a limited space on the panel but we
might get to find out who they're going
to be plus if you remember HBO is really
good about showing off bonus footage
they're really good about posting freak
free bonus content so it's really
amazing so I have a feeling if you
remember how the star children were
beatboxing on the last DVD set I haven't
feeling that some of the vine videos
that Maisie Williams and so for sophie
Turner had been making will make it on
to this year's blu-ray release if you
haven't seen them all their vines are
available you have to scroll through
their twitter feed though but they're
really funny the other big bit of news
that they just announces the neil
marshall is going to return to direct
the season four finale it's just
significant because obviously they just
started filming and they were already
talking about the finale they didn't
talk about what they're going to be
doing in the finale they didn't talk
about Lady Stoneheart Ernie the other
big you know WTF moments that could
happen but as Catelyn Stark is actually
on the panel there's a good chance that
she could be coming back to the series
but then again Robb Stark is also on the
panel and after the events of season 3
spoilers sorry I won't mention it we're
not really sure what's going to happen
with those characters that's your cue to
search my cue for the videos from season
3 so you can find out what happened to
them don't worry if you want to find out
I did a lot of videos for it so you can
find out that way I do have a feeling
that a big point of discussion will be
the material that will deviate from the
books in season 4 if you remember
they're going to combine a lot of
elements from the second half of book 3
and booked for to be part of season 4
but they're also going to deviate a lot
from that story as a lot of people that
have died aren't dead and a lot of
people that aren't dead in the series or
I've already been killed off just in
favor of keeping the cast really small
so in other big news kit harington who's
going to be there is also doing another
panel with matt smith from Doctor Who
Fame that i'll also be trying to upload
the footage from that'll be in ballroom
20 and i think it's on thursday so
expect that footage too so I'm really
excited that's actually a panel for a
bunch of different big hero actors so
it'll be like kit Harrington who plays
Jon Snow Matt Smith plays dr. who and a
bunch of other actors from other big
series like The Walking Dead so it'll be
a lot of fun like I said be sure to
subscribe below to get all my comic con
videos in the meantime you can check out
my other comic con previews by clicking
here
you can check out some big news for
korra season 2 by clicking here get
excited Game of Thrones is going to be
awesome at comic-con high fives everyone
you